ce raid vous voulez des threads et quoi
chaque vidéo sereine on va apprendre
comment on dit serait dans une autre
langue
aujourd'hui en allemand fadden les amis
aujourd'hui nous n'allons pas faire un
thread twitter comme nous avons
l'habitude de le faire mais on va faire
bien pire parce qu'aujourd'hui c'est des
histoires vraies à chaque fois je suis
excité quand je fais ces vidéos live là
je le suis encore plus parce que je
viens de lire mais des dizaines
d'histoires et mec je deviens parano
j'ai l'impression d'être suivie que des
gens me veulent du mal aujourd'hui c'est
un peu comme quand on était autour du
feu en colonie de vacances avec des
potes etc on se racontait des histoires
flippante qu'on avait vécu sauf qu'il ya
pas de feu ça n'a donc rien à voir mais
c'est pas bien un peu pareil toutes ces
histoires ont été postées par des
utilisateurs résident sur un set qui
s'appelle let's not mythe le principe
c'est que chacun raconte l'histoire la
plus flippante qu'il a vécu dans sa vie
il est question de vrais événements de
vrais trucs un peu fous qui peuvent nous
aussi nous arriver et c'est trés creepy
meadows ne devenez pas parano on est là
juste pour passer un bon moment et se
divertir c'est parti j'entends des voix
la première histoire et celle de john en
vrai donne pas son nom mais je vais
appeler john pour soi plus sa part
raconté un jeune homme de 21 ans devenu
récemment policiers et récemment
célibataire voilà sa copie la larguer sa
rivale de millions d'hommes tous les
jours ce conseil de ses amis john va
installer et utiliser l'application
kindle et c'est son premier date que je
vais vous raconter jaune à un match avec
une fille très très belle sur
l'application il est très content les
deux parlent et s'entendent bien et à
lui propose rapidement un rendez vous en
disant qu'elle a un plan koulou on peut
observer les étoiles une charmante idée
pour un premier rendez vous romantique
sympathique
alors john monte dans sa voiture et va
la chercher chez elle puis se dirige
vers cet espace ouvert où on peut avoir
une très belle vue sur les étoiles au
milieu de la vie sauvage des animaux en
arrivant sur les lieux samantha sonde
est le guide à travers les champs pour
se poser à un endroit et observer les
étoiles comme prévu mais pendant qu'ils
s'avancent dans les bois il observe au
loin des phares d'une voiture
des phares qui se rapproche très très
très très vite de sa propre voiture et
un van apparaît et se colle à sa voiture
l'empêchant d'avancer jon diat samantha
de rester dans la voiture prend sa lampe
torche et descend pour aller voir très
bonne paire de couilles moi j'aurais
fait une marche arrière
illico et j'aurais ajouté samantha forêt
il s'approche du valais constatent que
le conducteur est très très grand et lui
demande poliment s'il peut reculer un
peu son 22 manières lui à se dégager et
à continuer d'avancer dans les bois le
conducteur du van lui répond très
poliment qu'il est propriétaire des
lieux et qui voulait pas du tout lui
faire peur il s'excuse
le conducteur du van lui souhaite alors
un bon rendez vous un bon des pays par
où que ce n'est pas la fin de l'histoire
jobs retourne alors dans sa voiture fin
de la frayeur mais il constate qu'à
partir de là il ya ça monte un qui
arrête pas d sur son téléphone et
d'envoyer des messages
ce qu'elle ne faisait pas du tout avant
john et samantha arrive à landreau mais
samantha voulais qu'ils aillent pour
observer les étoiles il descendre de
leur voiture ils les regardent et
environ une heure plus tard bim les
phares du van rée apparaissent au loin
et se rapproche très très très très vite
de le van peel en arrivant devant la
voiture de john et samantha cours dans
la voiture du conducteur du van
à partir de là john explique qu'il
comprend parfaitement qui s'est fait
[ __ ] qu'il est dans la merde
le conducteur du van sort du van charge
john elle fait tomber par terre
heureusement john réussi à le mettre sur
le dos et à se relever et voit sa vente
à prendre un tuyau en métal dans le van
qui le menace en dix ans on a des armes
à feu obéit nous de nous ton argent est
ta voiture
à ce stade vous nous ont dit oui tout de
suite ya aucun problème prenez tout mais
mon t-shirt mais john elle a 21 ans il
est jeune il vient d'être policier et il
pense que c'est tom cruise et 10 n'ont
jamais john sort son arme à feu la
pointe vers eux en disant qu'il est
policier
gros moment de blanc entre nos trois
interlocuteurs mais ils obéissent et
arrêtent leurs conneries john retourne
dans sa voiture il l'appelle le 911 et
l'appellent ses collègues il donne son
nom son numéro de badge il explique la
situation et des collègues à lui rappelé
qu'en vitesse pour l'aider parce qu'on
ne sait pas ce qu'il ya dans ce van van
ces grands mecs ça peut contenir
beaucoup de choses parallèlement
samantha et son complice s'enfuit dans
les bois orvane john reste sage il
attend ses collègues avant de faire quoi
que ce soit surtout ne pas agir seuls
dans cette situation c'est pau c'est
entièrement faux il se dirigea la
poursuite du vaccin ou john et pendant
qu'ils poursuivent en trois sont très
brillants et voit des modes of flash qui
partent de l'autre voiture il se fait
tirer dessus totalement je rappelle que
tout cela est un des outsiders on parle
d'un des teens d'earl actuellement ça
n'a aucun sens mais au moment où ils
voient les plages vénère de la voiture
ils s'arrêtent clairement sa fierté par
comme ça dans les l'aération de la clean
up son sergent et son officier
d'instruction arrive pour l'aider en
renfort et ils se lancent tous les trois
à la poursuite du valises et de le
retrouver et non perdu de vue ils le
trouvent et y avait des couteaux du
ruban adhésif du liquide pour briquer
une quantité indécente de munitions des
menottes et ce qui semblait être du sang
séché
juste ça heureusement personne n'a été
blessé même si john est traumatisé des
applications de rencontre je pense qu'on
ne peut pas faire un pire premier deit
ça n'existe pas c'est trop creepy
michael situation on dirait vraiment un
[ __ ] de film ce mec a vécu un film
d'horreur en vrai qu heureusement que
c'était un policier et qu'il avait une
arme de poing pour le coup dans cette
situation ça me fout les mecs ça me fait
le seul frisson que j'ai jamais trop
aimé les applications de rencontre ce
que je trouve ça un peu glauque des fois
mais jamais je me suis dit que ça
pouvait arriver ça coince effroyable
mais alors il est temps de vous raconter
à des mises aux normes et qui eut
rag look est plus courte mais qui fait
bien bien flipper l'oea a 22 ans et elle
explique que cet événement s'est passé
un an et demi avant qu'elle écrive ce
poste sur reddit elle vient d'emménager
dans son premier appartement est elle
encore savez dans le truc où tu
commandes des objets et tu reçois des
cartons sur soi ton canapé etc
elle encore dans tout le processus
d'aménagement elle explique que la porte
qui mène à son appartement se verrouille
automatiquement quand elles se ferment
ce jour là elle va chercher son courrier
en étant au téléphone avec son petit ami
puis elle revient dans son appartement
elle commence à ouvrir son courrier à
lire des lettres des impôts ce genre de
choses en ouvrant un let elle fait
tomber son téléphone qui fait un petit
rebond hop et qui va légèrement sous le
lit elle s'allonge alors sur le sol est
un endroit pour récupérer son téléphone
est là elle observe le pire truc
possible il ya quelqu'un doha elle qui
est sous son lit alors c'est une peur
qu'on a tous mais moi j'ai toujours
pensé que c'est impossible que ça arrive
mais ça lui arrive est vraiment là elle
explique que ses yeux s'écarquillent
quelle envie d'hurler mais que comme le
mec est de dos et qu'il ne peut pas la
voir elle fait comme si elle n'avait pas
elle récupère son téléphone elle dit à
l'interlocuteur qui est toujours au bout
du fil désolé j'ai fait tomber mon
téléphone je vais prendre une douche je
vous rappelle juste après et elle se
dirige dans sa salle de bain l amp
dedans elle verrouille la porte à clé
elle fait couler l'eau de la douche et
comme elle habite au premier étage
elle n'ouvre la fenêtre de la salle de
bains et elle saute elle appelle la
police qui lui dit de rester pas très
loin de là partent mais caché quand même
les à partir de là elle attend l'arrivée
de police les yeux rivés sur son
appartement pour voir si quelqu'un en
sort mais c'est une sur femmes c'est
incroyable et héroïque comme ça avoir le
sang froid de ne pas crier alors qu'un
inconnu chez toi sur ton lit comment il
a fait mais gros il ya un pissenlit sur
mon lit je crie par réflexe bas qui se
fait là elle ya un mec entier de dos est
bon pour vous l'idée de reprendre le
téléphone est de continuer la discussion
comme si c'était rien passer et tu
donnes l'assurance au gac et souli que
tu l'as pas vu alors tu l'a parfaitement
vu bref c'est incroyable respect en
croix pour cette femme qui est
légendaire légendaire niveau légendaire
alors elle est donc en train d'attendre
la police est là aussi entre temps
appelé son petit ami qu'il a rejoint il
attend avec elle et enfin la police
arrive elle leur donne les clés de
l'appartement et il se dirige dedans
pour voir si le mec est encore là et
pour l'arrêter c'est le cas quelques
instants plus tard deux policiers sort
de l'appartement avec un mec qui a un
air très fatigué un regard de fou mais
qui se débat pas les policiers vont dire
à layrac
elle a agi merveilleusement bien même si
on savait déjà parce que l'homme
attendait devant l'entrée de la salle de
bain avec l'un de ses couteaux de
cuisine voilà pour probablement faire
des fajitas avec alliès up large là sur
mon bureau vite fait c'est bon la
personne en fait le mec était rentré
dans son appartement pendant qu'elle
récupérer son courrier la porte c'était
pâques laquelle c'était juste posé vous
savez et du coup il avait pu en profiter
pour lui rentrer se cacher sous l'île et
à nous explique ensuite que dès le
lendemain son petit ami a emménagé avec
elle parce que ça l'avait complètement
traumatisée et c'est vrai que déjà quand
tu te fais comme brûler tu sais qu'il ya
des gens qui sont allés chez toi quand
tu étais pas là et kits ont dérobé des
affaires ça te traumatisme est vraiment
mais là quand tu vois qu'il ya quelqu'un
chez toi cachée de tes propres yeux ça
doit vraiment être une situation
tellement stressante traumatisé c'est
sûr donc bravo léa respect à toi et est
maintenant pendant que les quatre années
qui suit - et des millions de gens vont
regarder sous notre lit tous les soirs
grâce à toi merci les amis troisième
histoire et celle là elle est tellement
horrible et encore une fois on est tombé
sur un héros vraiment les gens qui
postent leurs histoires là sur ce thread
ils sont légendaires grosse et des héros
de film alors valentin on va l'appeler
comme ça
j'invente des prix valentin a 21 ans et
le soir ils décidé dans un bar avec un
ami à lui sur le chemin du bar son pote
était déjà en train de boire donc quand
ils sont arrivés il était déjà
complètement fait en arrivant en bas il
s'assoit tous les deux et il ya une
fille qui s'appelle candice qui est très
mignonne qui vient s'asseoir à côté
d'eux pour leur part les voilà jeudi de
voix là puisque jusque là tout est
normal
alors je profite je dis voilà valentin
remarquer la des très beaux cheveux roux
mais que c'est pas naturel
il pense que c'est un tueur bref c'est
une petite réflexion mais bon sans
importance alors qu'en dise fait avec
valentin et son ami mais elles sont plus
intéressés par son ami valentin il se
dit [ __ ] c'est peut-être parce que lui
il est très très bourg et donc elle
pense qu'elle a plus de chance avec lui
donc valentin fait semblant d'être aussi
bourré que son pote pour attirer
l'attention de candice
allez petit vous savez la petite guerre
de séduction là en soirée et blablabla
alors ça parle ça parle évidemment
valentin il se dit que peut-être qu'elle
est là juste pour avoir des boissons
gratuites qu'elle fait semblant de
s'intéresser à eux donc but de boire des
bières ou je sais pas quoi gratuitement
et elle va répondre de la meilleure des
manières elle va leur payer avoir elle
même sauf que ça va durer un moment elle
n'arrête pas de commander de nouveaux
des cocktails pour eux tout le temps
tout le temps tout le temps à tel point
qu'au bout d'un moment valentin il sait
pas si elle est là pour son ami ou pour
lui-même tout est un peu floue c'est
bizarre le pod valentin va aux toilettes
souffre qui revient jamais parce qu'en
fait les videurs l'on dégagé la boîte
parce qu'ils étaient trop bourré du coup
valentin c'est un vrai pote qui sort de
la boîte et rejoint son ami pour veiller
sur lui parce que c'est plus sobre des
deux donc c'est à lui d'être a entre
guillemets le gardien et gandhi suit
valentin dehors ils se retrouvent donc
tous les trois devant le bar et la
candice regard le pas de valentin et lui
propose de
de venir chez elle avec elle voilà
l'invite sauf qu'il est tellement bourré
qu'il arrive à peine à répondre valentin
comprend donc que son pote et plus du
tout maître de ses actes et de ses
paroles et du coudiat qu'en dise non non
il peut pas venir avec toi il est trop
bourré la sava part parce qu'il n'a pas
envie que son pote se réveille dans une
maison inconnue sans sa voiture et en
n'ayant aucune idée de ce qui s'est
passé la veille soudainement qu'on dise
elle s'intéresse alors énormément à 20
ans
à tel point qu'au bout d'un moment elle
propose même à valentin de d'offrir un
taxi à son ami pour qu'il rentre chez
lui et que eux de aille chez candice à
la switch très très vite quand même de
crush là c'est très bizarre mais bon ok
si toi tu il il accompagne la mise
valentin jusqu'à son taxi puis ensuite
il se dirige vers la voiture de candice
sur chemin lui propose de s'arrêter pour
acheter de l'alcool dans un magasin et
continuer à boire sur le trajet elle
insiste sur le fait que c'est elle qui
perd à l'alcool et qui a pas de soucis
sauf que valentin il est pas chaud il a
déjà beaucoup but sauf que candice elle
insista valentin a peur de gâcher ses
chances y refuse donc il lui dit ok ok
achètent moins une bouteille d'alcool et
nous tu ailles de jus de pomme et on va
boire mais ils comptent pas boire
direction la maison de candice et tandis
bois des toutes petites gorgées d'alcool
elle n'arrête pas d'insister pour
valentin boivent boivent et boivent à
tel point que là ça devient pas normal
c'est trop bizarre d'insister à ce point
pour que quelqu'un boivent ça n'a aucun
sens mais valentin encore une fois il a
peur de la froisser et de gâcher ses
chances donc il va apprendre des gorges
et d'alcool qui garde dans sa bouche et
qui va recracher dans la bouteille de
jus de pomme il va aussi la tester en
l'appelant autrement que par son prénom
il va l'appeler car lalanne a
volontairement elle n'a pas du tout
réagir comme s'ils sont fichés
complètement là ça fait un truc chelou
de plus normalement si tu es intéressé
par quelqu'un et qu'ils se trompent de
prénoms en a planté un peu vexé quand
même tu réagis tu ça y est ils arrivent
enfin tous les deux devant la maison de
candice il rentre et en rentrant
valentin fait exprès de tomber pour
faire croire qu'il est vraiment vraiment
très très bon et l aide à marche elle le
tient la porte d'entrée n'est pas
verrouillé donc il rentrait après être
entré elle ferme la porte d'entrée à
double tour bref il est tard le soir on
ferme la porte d'entrée par peur que
quelqu'un en par effraction et se cache
sous son lit par exemple un yes valentin
lui demande s'il peut aller dans la
salle de bain et en entrant il
verrouille cette dernière il se regarde
dans le miroir en se disant [ __ ] il ya
un truc qui cloche c'est pas normal là
il ya eu de trop de trucs bizarres et là
il entend candice parler dans le salon à
quelqu'un il chuchoté
babet se lever c'est vous qui le faites
ok vous fait quoi exactement et pourquoi
fallait-il qu'il soit très bourg est
pour vous le fassiez valentin sort de la
salle de bains jusqu'au de façon à faire
d'autre il voit qu'en dise et là gros
bad pour valentin c'est pas qu'en dise
qui a devant lui c'est une autre
personne
c'était une autre fille qui avait les
mêmes cheveux que candice cheveux qui
était donc probablement une perruque et
que candice avait donné sept autres
personnes pour faire genre que c'est
candice valentin en voyant ça effet
comme léa il fait genre qu'il a rien vu
que tout est normal et il sourit à cette
fille en lui disant est ce que je peux
retourner dans la salle de bain je suis
toujours pas bien la fille lui répond
que tout va bien qui a pas de souci mais
elle a quand même envie qu'ils se
dépêchent valentin retourne dans la
salle de bain il l'entend murmurer
quelque chose à quelqu'un d'autre qui
lui murmure quelque chose en retour sauf
que la deuxième voie c'est pas une voix
féminine c'est une voix masculine et
donc une troisième personne dans cette
maison et valentin n'a pas vu et nous
explique qu'il n'a pas compris ce qu'ils
ont dit c'est pas concentrés pour
entendre leurs mots son but c'était
juste de se barrer le plus vite possible
de cette situation très dangereuse alors
hasard des choses il a fait comme léa il
a ouvert la fenêtre de la salle de bains
il a sauté et il a sprinté pendant 40
minutes il a appelé un taxi
il est rentré chez et depuis ce jour il
se pose plein de questions ils demandent
ce qui se serait passé cette nuit là
s'il était resté dans la maison pour
quoi qu'en dise faisait boire absolument
un mec pour le ramener chez elle et le
confier à deux potes à elle est ce que
c'était pour faire du sexe thorsen vous
savez quand vous avez des vidéos
pornographiques de quelqu'un et que vous
demander des rançons pour pas les
diffuser
est-ce que c'était pour le kidnapper
est-ce que c'était pour lui faire des
trucs bizarres il sait pas et ça le rend
ouf valentin moi maintenant c'est comme
ça va être un critère quand je prends un
appart ou une maison je veux gras salle
de bains une fenêtre forcément ce jeu
pas être dans la situation de ces gens
et qui est pas de fenêtre pour partir
c'est horrible les amis c'est la fin de
cette vidéo sur les histoires véridiques
il y en a énormément là j'en ai
sélectionné des différents qu'il y en a
pas mal qui se ressemblent mine de rien
ou 20 août c'est la même mécanique là je
voulais que ce soit un truc très
différents je vais t'en fais un
quatrième et je me rends compte que
cette dernière histoire était très
longue et très prenante
alors y'a pas besoin je la réserve
peut-être pour un autre épisode le pouce
bleus si vous voulez un épisode bien sûr
c'est que je suis en train de faire je
c'est fou comme je suis pas je veux dire
en soirée à plein de gens en france ou
partout dans le monde qui finissent la
soirée chez quelqu'un d'autre pour se
faire des câlins
vous parlez vous jouez à smash bros même
si j'en doute et il ya une infime chance
pour que tu te retrouves dans des
situations comme ça quoi donc je trouve
ça terrible donc faites bien attention
si vous rentrez touareg vous allez chez
un inconnu assurez-vous que ce soit
quelqu'un de clean et pas de blizzard
donc soyez attentifs en soirée et ne
buvait pas trop voir ne buvait pas tout
court
au moins vous serez pas fait dans le
conscient de ce qui se passe de ce qui
vous entoure et vous pouvez remarquer
tous ces petits détails comme permet à
valentin de sortir de cette situation et
puis voilà sinon
c'est noël à bientôt je souhaite de très
bonnes feuilles est passé de très bons
moments avec vos proches avec vos amis
bref avec tout le monde j'espère vous
aurez de jolis cadeaux et puis je vous
dis à très dans une prochaine vidéo
portez vous bien reposez vous bien aussi
c'est les vacances ou cliqué bientôt les
gens à la prochaine
[Musique]
fait